do you know that 75 percent of searchers
never click past the first page of the
search results
moreover as per the research carried out
by backlinko
only 0.78
of searchers click results from the
second page of the search results
if you notice this is a negligible
number showing minimum or no possibility
that the user will click on your website
that appears on the second page that is
why you need to appear on the first page
of the search result and rank high
and this makes search engine
optimization
also known as seo one of the most
crucial aspects of digital marketing
a very warm welcome to this new video by
simply learn in which you will get a
brief overview of search engine
optimization
by the end of this video you will have a
better understanding of digital
marketing and its components we will
have a brief look into what is seo and
its importance
next we will understand how search
engines work
and what are different types of seo
moving forward we will discuss essential
tools required for best search engine
optimization practices
and finally we will end the session by
understanding case study job scenarios
and what the future holds for seo
before we begin consider subscribing to
our channel and hit the bell icon if you
love our videos
so without any further ado let's first
briefly understand
what digital marketing is
traditional marketing strategies like
newspaper advertisements pamphlet
promotion billboard advertisements are
slowly overtaken by digital marketing
promoting products and services on the
online platform using digital technology
is called digital marketing
now you must be thinking for sure that
what are digital marketing methods
through which one can promote their
products and services on the internet
let me tell you there are several
components of digital marketing let us
have a quick look at each one of them
first we have search engine optimization
also known as seo
with search engine optimization one can
get relevant traffic through search
results with the help of search engines
we will understand this more clearly as
we move ahead with this video
next we have social media marketing also
known as smm the promotion of products
and services using social media platform
is called social media marketing some
social media platforms include youtube
twitter
facebook instagram etc
moving towards email marketing it is one
of the important components of digital
marketing
promoting products and services through
emails is called email marketing
now let's know what affiliate marketing
is
when one business pays to another
business or influencer to promote its
products and services it is known as
affiliate marketing
getting to know about mobile marketing
mobile marketing promotes products and
services using devices like phones
tablets or mobile devices
some mobile marketing strategies include
sms marketing in-app advertisements
location-based advertisements etc
content marketing
content marketing is creating and
distributing high quality content to
attract relevant traffic
content can be of any form like a blog
article video or podcast
and the last one search engine marketing
also known as sem
search engine marketing is a practice of
advertising the content such that it
appears at the top of the search results
page
it is also known as pay per click
we will discuss all the components in
detail in the upcoming videos in this
video let's focus on search engine
optimization
mid 1990 was the initial phase when
content providers started optimizing
their websites for search engines
by 1997
content providers started manipulating
search engines to get higher rankings so
algorithm for search engines were
regularly updated to lower the risk of
manipulation
in 2001 there were rumors that seo would
no longer be in action and would be
replaced by search engine marketing well
this never happened
in these 20 years various growing seo
techniques have improved the web
presence of websites and will continue
for many more years so let's understand
what is search engine optimization
the practice of getting traffic
organically through the search results
with the help of search engine is called
search engine optimization
although being one of the most important
components of digital marketing
seo has had some myths floating around
it
let's have a look at them
only famous brands can rank high in
search results
yes it is a myth
with good seo techniques anyone can rank
high in search results
competitors are way too strong so it
isn't easy to rank high in this case
this can be a bit difficult but it can
be easily overcome with good competitor
analysis skills and one can attain high
ranks and search results
a website with more pages can rank high
well it depends on the quality of
content page has
if the content is high quality even the
website with fewer pages can rank high
to rank there is a need to spend a lot
of money
one can rank high with some strategies
and techniques without spending a penny
now that we have debunked the myths
around seo let's understand why seo is
important
seo increases the popularity of your
brand product or services among the
audience thereby increasing the chances
of conversion of lead to customer
traffic obtained organically is more
consistent
once you are aware of seo strategies and
start gaining visibility in search
results
your site will gain constant traffic
that will keep increasing with time
with seo one can reach a large audience
to promote products and services
businesses can acquire audiences from
both the national and international
levels
seo builds trust among the audience for
instance if your web page is available
on google search results the audience
finds it worthy of trust because of its
online presence
your competitors are doing it then you
should also do it this could be a
serious note
if your competitors are doing this to
rank high and gain visibility you must
also do it or remain back in the race
there are three types of seo that you
can implement for the growth of your
business
before moving towards it it is necessary
to understand how search engines work
let's understand it with the help of an
analogy
susan started a business of handmade
toys she failed to gain enough customers
using traditional marketing methods like
newspaper advertisements and banners
so she thought of putting the business
online thereby creating a website
the website was completely optimized for
search engines and was soon visible on
the search result pages
the website started acquiring the
traffic which ultimately became her
customers
the sales were boosted to an unexpected
level and the revenue has increased
exponentially
a good decision brought huge success to
susan's business
susan was thrilled with joy
when a thought struck across her mind
how are search engines able to find her
website
so
search engines can be google bing
etc which work on three basic steps
that are
crawling
indexing
and ranking
first we will understand crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send the web spiders also
known as crawlers or robots or search
engine bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image web page video
or anything else present on the web
this process is known as crawling
soon after the discovery of content
web spiders start storing the url of the
content into the search index and this
process is known as indexing
once the content is indexed it appears
in the search results for the relevant
searches
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant search results are taken
from the index and displayed from most
relevant to least relevant on the search
result pages
this process is known as ranking
now as you're familiar with the working
of search engines let's dive deep into
types of seo
that is
on page seo
off page seo
and technical seo
we will start with on page seo
optimizing a web page to gain visibility
and rank high in search results
and get relevant traffic is known as
on-page seo
some on-page seo techniques include
optimizing content
adding attractive titles and meta
descriptions
adding internal and external links on
the web page
adding ssl certifications for the
website
optimizing images for search results etc
next is off page seo
actions taken outside the web page or a
website to rank high in search results
is known as off-page seo
some off-page seo techniques include
building backlinks
blogging and submitting articles on
other websites
promoting content on social media etc
and the last one is technical seo
optimizing technical elements of a
website such that search engines can
easily crawl and index the web pages is
known as technical seo
some technical optimizations include
reducing the page loading speed of a web
page to a minimum
submitting site maps to search engines
have organized website structure as it
informs search engines about the
essential pages of the website
adding redirections for the deleted urls
or temporarily moving urls
identify duplicate content and replace
it with unique content
don't worry too much about it we will
cover these in detail in the upcoming
videos
now to optimize the website there are
lot of tools available
few from google and few third-party
tools as well
let's have a look at these tools
keyword research tools includes google
keyword planner
keyword tool dot io
rfs
mos etc
on on-page off-page and technical seo
tools
rfs helps to estimate search traffic
know ranking history monitor outbound
links
generate backlink reports etc
sem rush is helpful for competitor
analysis
generating new ideas for content
analyzing website traffic
website analytics and more
google analytics helps generate website
traffic reports track activities like
bounce rate pages per session
track online campaigns when integrated
with adwords
it also has features to know a user's
location how long the user stays on the
website tracking sales report etc
google search console
helps to understand
how the search engine sees the website
generates reports for clicks and
impressions of your page in search
results
carries out url
submits a site map
finds error pages like 404 and more for
the website
here are some other tools that may be
helpful while working with seo
google tag manager helps add and update
google ads without changing site code
google trends helps get trend
predictions seasonal trends find
relevant trending topics etc grammarly
helps check readability that is how
easily your content is readable for the
user
checking pulsarism to maintain unique
content etc
page speed insights help analyze page
performance and suggest improvements for
a web page
now you must be thinking
can seo actually bring success to your
business
well we have a small case study for you
to let you know how to go from zero to
hero
let's assume there is a company named
express bakers that has started a cakes
business that focused on instant cake
baking and delivery
rather than choosing the traditional
methods of advertisements they decided
to put their business online
express bakers
created a website for their business
and completed all the technicalities
like submitting site maps ensuring easy
crawlable site structure and optimizing
paid speed
soon their business started gaining
visibility in search results
but still the sales were lower than
expected
after hiring an expert they understood
that traffic on the website is very low
so they made up their mind to follow the
seo strategies thereby optimizing the
website
relevant keywords like instant cakes
cake delivery instant cake mix instant
cake delivery instant cake delivery near
me instant flavored cakes etc were added
to the website pages
express bakers added cake images with
description time of delivery choice of
flavor and cake base and cost all images
were optimized with alter tag so that
search engines should understood the
image
relevant internal and external links
were added so that search engines can
discover other pages of the website
and users can find other products like
cookies and pastries by express bakers
express bakers became smart during the
website optimization
they knew that to gain massive traffic
they needed to promote their products on
the website and other public platforms
as well
thus they added articles on instant cake
baking recipes
how to make flavored cake base instantly
how to make instant whipped cream and
many others on the blogging platforms
like reddit hub pages blogs by google
and also added the website's relevant
urls in the article express bakers were
now unstoppable
they kept on posting on social media
platforms about their instant cakes and
delivery facilities which helped in the
brand building
efforts by express bakers increased
their brand awareness and attracted
customers to their product
soon there was an exponential growth in
website traffic and sales were at their
peak
express bakers generated high revenue
through the increase in sales in just
few simple steps they got success in
hand
this is the story of success by express
bakers
all businesses dream of such success
so they try to get their online presence
thus there is a vast requirement for seo
executives in the market
in the upcoming part of the video let's
discuss various job roles under seo
with tough competition to rank on the
search engines and app stores there is a
huge demand in industry for seo experts
there are various types of roles in seo
some popular ones are
seo associate seo analyst seo executive
seo manager and seo expert
let's first talk about seo associates
seo associate is responsible for
performing keyword research and
implementing seo strategies to improve
organic ranking
the average base pay of an seo associate
in u.s is between dollar fifty nine
thousand to dollar eighty thousand per
annum and in india is two lakh twenty
eight thousand rupees per annum
next is seo analyst
seo analyst is responsible for keyword
research competitor analysis tracking
organic traffic and conversion rate
the average base pay of an seo analyst
in the us is between dollar forty eight
thousand to dollar seventy eight
thousand per annum and in india is two
lakh twenty eight thousand rupees per
annum
understanding the responsibilities of
seo executives
an seo executive is responsible
for gathering analytics reports
creating seo friendly content and
implementing on-page and off-page
techniques
the average base pay of an seo executive
in u.s
is dollar 39
382
per annum and in india is in between 1
lakh 92 000 to 3 lakhs 62 000 rupees per
annum
an seo manager is responsible for
analyzing reports of the campaigns
developing content marketing strategies
managing a team of seo experts
fixing technical seo issues
and more
the average base pay of seo manager in
us is
seventy two thousand six hundred fifty
two per annum
and in india
is eight lakh seventy nine thousand
rupees
moving towards the job responsibilities
of seo expert seo expert is responsible
for creating keywords and content
strategy link building strategies
competitor analysis and reports and
campaigning the average base pay of an
seo expert in u.s
is in between dollar fifty three
thousand two dollars seventy eight
thousand per annum
and in india
is two lakh seventy six thousand rupees
per annum some companies hiring for
significant roles under seo are
microsoft
disney
siemens
udemy
and deloitte
before ending the session
let's know what is future of seo
as every online business wants high
ranking and visibility in search engines
seo plays a crucial role in the journey
of any business thereby creating
enormous job opportunities and with
companies shifting to digital space
now more than ever after the pandemic
the importance of seo in the future
cannot be overstated so let's try to
understand what the future holds for seo
let's first discuss urls
urls are the standard way of
representing the website's address thus
urls will remain an essential factor in
the coming future
next is auto generated content
machine generated content will be
accepted by search engines if and only
if humans have reviewed the content
before uploading
coming to page speed
as per the data provided by google
as page load time increases from 1 to 3
seconds
bounce rate increases to 32 percent
therefore by improving paid speed a user
gets easy access to required information
and so paid speed will continue to
remain a significant ranking factor for
future seo
moving towards content creation
create content that focuses on user
search intent
add content that user needs as this will
be an essential ranking factor in the
coming future
keep the old content of your website
updated
if you are not doing so my friend you
lose valuable traffic
when you update the pages content
search engines are notified of the
update and updated content is again
indexed
adding more value to your page
if the page is not updated frequently
you may lose the search ranking within a
time span thereby losing traffic
backlinks will remain an important
ranking factor
as it shows other people's trust in your
content thereby adding a plus to your
rankings
so guys that is all for today's session
we will meet again in another video with
another exciting topic related to seo
until then if you have any queries do
let us know in the comment section below
and don't forget to subscribe to simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here